- LET'S MEET OUR SKATERS.
SAY HELLO TO LIZ,
A PUBLICITY AND EVENT PLANNER
FROM SAN DIEGO, CALIFORNIA.
- I'M LIZ.
MY CATCHPHRASE I THINK
AT THIS POINT IS "THANK YOU."
MY PET PEEVE IS BEING
CALLED RIDICULOUS.
UP UNTIL THIS POINT,
I'VE DATED
A LOT OF OLDER GUYS.
- THERE'S A TONE
IN YOUR VOICE...
- [high-pitched]
THERE IS?
- THAT SOUNDS LIKE
WHAT YOU'VE BEEN DOING
WITH OLDER MEN MAYBE HAS NOT
BEEN WORKING.
- WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
- HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
DATING A YOUNGER MAN?
A MUCH YOUNGER MAN?
- LIKE, I LOVE TO HAVE FUN,
BUT I DON'T WANT TO DATE
SOMEONE WHO'S, LIKE, WILD.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN.
BUT...I'LL DO IT.
- LET'S MEET
HER SKATING PARTNER.
C-CZAR IS A TOILET BABY
FROM ALHAMBRA.
- MY NAME IS C-CZAR.
I'M 17 YEARS OLD.
MY CATCHPHRASE IS
"LET THEM EAT CAKE!"
AND MY PET PEEVE
IS SAYING I'M SORRY.
- WHAT KIND OF WOMAN
ARE YOU LOOKING FOR?
C-CZAR?
I NEED YOU TO--
- HA HA HA!
BASICALLY, LIKE,
I'M LOOKING FOR SOMEONE
WHO ACCEPTS ME
FOR WHO I AM,
WHO'S, UM--
- C-CZAR?
- WHAT'S UP, MAN?
- YOU WERE IN THE MIDDLE
OF A SENTENCE.
- OKAY, SO, LIKE,
WHATEVER THE QUESTION WAS
IS LIKE SLIT MY NECK.
- DON'T--THAT'S VERY SHARP.
- YOU'RE NOT MY DAD.
- ALL RIGHT.
LET'S PUT THESE TWO
IN THE RINK
AND SEE IF THEY GET
INTO THE GROOVE.
- [grunting]
AAH!
- HEY HEY!
- OH, MY GOD.
I'M SORRY, I'M, LIKE,
WAITING HERE, LIKE, FOR A DATE.
- LIKE PRINCE CHARMING?
- WHAT?
- WELL, RIBBIT!
BLAP! BLAP! BLAP! BLAP!
IT'S PRINCE CHARMING!
I'M C-CZAR.
- OH.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
- NICE TO MEET YOU.
- OH, ALL RIGHT.
[laughter]
- I LIKE HOW YOU LOOK.
- YOU'RE, LIKE,
SCARY ON THE OUTSIDE,
BUT, LIKE, VERY SWEET
ON THE IN.
- YEAH, LIKE A CROISSANT.
- DO YOU EAT A LOT
OUT OF VENDING MACHINES?
- I LOVE CANDY FOR DINNER.
WHAT ABOUT YOU?
SKATE WITH ME.
SKATE BACKWARDS.
- YOU'RE, LIKE,
PUSHING MY BUTTONS.
- YOU LIKE IT?
- SO, LIKE, YOU'VE VERY GOOD
ON THE ICE.
- I'M GOOD ON THE ICE,
BUT I'M ALSO GOOD IN BED.
GIVE ME YOUR HELMET!
[laughing]
- NO, I WON'T!
- SPIN AROUND!
- DON'T! DON'T DO IT.
LIKE, THAT'S THE WRONG BUTTON
TO PUSH!
NO, THAT WASN'T FUN.
- WHAT? I'M JUST BEING FLIRTY.
AAH!
NO, YOU CAN'T STOP ME.
YOU CAN'T STOP ME.